hey Vsauce I've got something special
for you today I'm sure you've heard of a
wing man before but have you ever heard
of a wing girl well guess what there's
two of them right now
they met with Ben and Mark in LA like a
few weeks ago and I said hey wait a
second ladies what do you think of guys
who are kind of geeky and they said Shh
No
we'll make a video instead and that's
exactly what they did so without further
ado lay back relax and enjoy the show
hey Vsauce what's up I'm Jack and I'm
star and we're the wing girls and we're
invading your channel just for one night
only so stay with us yes so we ran into
Ben and Mark from Key of Awesome and
they wanted us to do something with
Michael yes so here we are and we're
gonna give a little bit of dating advice
maybe some of you need it maybe some of
you don't that might as well watch not
either way what are you gonna do yeah
you're on the Vsauce channel anyways we
have videos like how to flirt how to
kiss how to get out of the friendzone
like that one that's the night one so if
you like any of that stuff
check us out so we wanted to talk about
geeks okay yes because we do love geeks
and we were both geeks in junior high
and high school and kind of still are
the thing to remember is like if you're
a geek now then you know maybe you are
getting picked on and maybe you're not
the hero of your school but those
football jocks over there are gonna be
working at Burger King when you're like
awesome one day you're working for being
awesome right and there's the Burger
King not there's anything wrong with
that no no totally okay I love fries
especially curly fries
yeah not no oh that is hot well we're
talking about no what are we talking
about so today we're gonna tell you how
to use being a geek quote-unquote to
your advantage with the ladies right
because we're not trying to turn you
into something you're not no we're just
saying hey this is your saying here's
what you should do with it
to get a girlfriend exactly just some
attention from the girls
exactly okay so interests are sexy no
matter what your interest is girls like
you can use it to your advantage yes say
you're really good at computers and you
spend your nights like taking apart your
harddrive and put it back together or
whatever if you see a girl in class that
needs computer help or you see that
she's got a really old computer like
offer to soup it up for her you know
like you've got the RAM tell her to
bring it over and you'll fix it like
Baylor instant holla and you know what's
weird that all that technical stuff is
the new form of chivalry but the other
thing you should remember is don't talk
her ear off about what you're doing
don't be like well I just had to unplug
a wire and then put this other thing in
there and ya don't hear it we don't even
know what yours is telling you about
what happened on Sex in the City just do
it and then give her the finished
product and be like you're wham bam
thank you ma'am
yeah that's hot okay guys so tell us
what your passion is what's your
interest that is really cool and that
you spend a lot of time on comment below
right here cuz we want to know yeah
what's your passion alright another
thing you can remember is group
activities equal face time all right
so if you've got all the latest
equipment you got the Wii you've got the
Xbox 305 you got you know all the latest
things and we really you know we know
we're talking about but if you got all
the latest equipment then you can invite
people over your household I'm a little
like here we just got a new copy of Just
Dance 2 you know that's a game um let's
play it together yeah and you know at
first I might just start out a bunch of
guys doing it and then you know they can
invite their sisters or their friends
and you guys can all like start hanging
out and try to go for a game that's like
an interactive one like I know they're
karaoke games out there tennis games
yeah that work everyone al and right I
love rock yeah Robin yeah right yeah and
drummer is a really sexy on either
drummer okay guys so use your niche to
get girls okay there are plenty of girls
out there that LARP that are gamers that
you know go to comic-con it's there may
be harder to find you might have to find
that some of them on the internet but
they are out there yeah you put yourself
out there and you're the only
guy out of all those kind of shy guys
that is actually talking to her you're
gonna win that's true I mean we went to
comic-con a couple years ago yeah there
were lots of girls there and you know
then you're kind of finding like-minded
people that are into the same stuff the
us you've already got a common ground to
start from yeah it's plenty to talk
about already that's right
you talk about Legend of Zelda we don't
show them how the videogame returns we
are as old a guy oh we did if he was
smoking okay guys so biggest thing to
remember is to just be yourself
that's huge yeah huge we don't want you
guys to turn into Brad Pitt if you want
you to be you and use what you've got to
your advantage
mm-hmm well sexy yeah and if you're
actually talking to girls you're ten
steps ahead of all your friends totally
so congrats and if you want to see our
video on why geeks make better
boyfriends then click here do it
like it right now because they do and
we'll tell you why
yes all right so thanks B sauce and
don't worry your channel will be going
back to normal it's the same thing we
did not invade it forever but if you you
know liked what you saw here and want a
little more then come on over to the
wing girls and see what we've got for
you